[Applaudissements]
de notre chaîne qui savent pas qu'ils
sont les animals mais je chaîne je le
sais ça c'est pour ça que je vous le dis
je recevrai payant delahousse dit ben
voilà on dépend du désir si tout d'un
coup moi j'ai une idée en or et que je
vais toujours proposé qu'une fois tous
les ans je vais proposer deux trois
idées d'émissions donc l'anecdote c'est
quelqu'un qui sait même pas que vous
étiez sur la charia jusqu'à 1000 fois
que des véhicules à bas coût qui dit la
gare et du film black et le patron de
construit maintenant bien mais c'est
vrai un jour de se la raconter nouveau
avec une avec mais c'est hallucinant je
me retrouve avec une barrière h oui
directrice qui est qui et sur france 2
elle me dit mais vous faites quoi je
juge boulanger à nemours
non elle dira ça marche bien elle
sentait qu'il se passait quelque chose
je sais pas clair et aussi demandé à des
animateurs sur notre chaîne non ça
faisait 15 ans que je faisais sur la
liberté c'est pour ça que moi c'est
d'éviter pendant que fut le seul
animateur que le pathfinder facteurs le
long de ma fille tranquille a peut-être
des gens sur des huit qui te connaissent
pas malgré tout est ce qu'il ya des
business différents c'est vrai c'est une
immense chaîne france télévisions c'est
combien de gens travaillent à france
télévisions on attendait iront la moitié
[Rires]
à l'est d'aix on va se faire un quiz
texte ou thierry mots je vous propose
des blagues autour de la table maudite
si ces textes qui les a sortis au
thierry moreau bien sûr tirer moreau ne
joue pas ça c'est notre scénario
alors si j'envoie un soufflé ou quoi que
ce soit à la mène là bas il a souffert
le monde ça les gars de chez monsieur et
vous préparez vous alors je suis quoi je
suis coffreur dans le bâtiment à vous
êtes gendarmes
c'est les gendarmes qui coffre
d'habitude ex ex à ces textes qui
faisait 15 ans
bon vous êtes frédéric frédéric donc je
suis brest et je suis coffreur donc dans
le bas de gendarmes
chico frères coffreur bancheur donc sur
ses légendes
un tout petit truc
normalement un jean-luc quand tu fais
cette vanne tu n'expliques pas derrière
mais comme on est c'est la deuxième
couche h et obligé elle savait rigoler
avant déjà sur avait rigolé on savait
rigoler gueule de cuxa fait de rigolade
de couches c'était du crabe et audry de
thierry thierry beccaro et sur le
plateau il faut qu'ils se tiennent à
carreau
c'est le moment ou jamais de faire votre
valérie et thierry se tiennent à carreau
[Musique]
alors quand les enfants sont malades
les gospels on tient bon désolé je veux
pas dire mais il ya plus un style chez
tex permis on dévale ringarde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais pour matane vieille femme c'est
pour ça parce que j'ai perdu toutes ses
bases il